Here's the math on why RSA works.
We know that the public key is e and
n and the private key is d,n.
We also know that n equals to p times q,
and p and q are prime numbers.
Therefore, quotient n is p
minus 1 times q minus 1.
The public key e and
the public key d are multiplicative
inverse of each other, mod potion n.
That's why we say the public key and
the private key are paired together.
And therefore when we compute X raised
the power of e times d it's the same as
X raised to the power of e times d
mod potion n which happens to be 1.
That is, let me compute X raised
to the power of e times d
is the same as X mod n.
So that is a quick recap of
the properties of the RSA public and
private keys.
Now, to encrypt a message m,
we raise m to the power of e mod n.
To decrypt, we take the ciphertext,
raise it to the power of d mod n.
This is the same as raising m
to the power of e times d mod n,
which is the same as m mod n
according to this property.
Since we require that the plain
text input is smaller than the key,
that means m mod n equal to m and
that's the original plaintext.
So this shows that
decryption indeed works.
As an exercise,
you can similarly verify that digital
signature under RSA also works.
Here's an example of RSA,
the keys are generated as follows.
We select two prime numbers.
p equal to 17, q equal to 11 so
n is p times q,
which is 187 and totient n
is p minus 1 times q minus 1
because p and q are prime numbers.
So in this case,
totient 187 is 16 times 10 which is 160.
For public key we select a number
that's relatively prime to totient n.
In this case, we select 7,
because 7 is relatively prime to 160.
The private key d, is the multiplicative
inverse of e Mod potion n.
So the multiplicative
inverse of 7 mod 160 is 23,
therefore the private key is 23.
To summarize the key generation process,
we have
the public key 7, 187,
public key 23, 187.
Suppose we use a public key to
encrypt the plaintext message 88.
We raised 88 to a power of 7 mod 187,
the result is 11.
To decrypt we raise 11 to
power of 23 and then mod 187.
The result is 88,
the same as the plaintext.